[Music]
that's just like on those just like Star
Trek everybody speaks English very well
sometimes they have accents but we think
we know how we came to be here on our
world we've studied this how did you
come to be what are you doing here we've
worked for millennia or many many orbits
of the Sun to reach this level we
believe that we came to be about a
hundred thousand orbits ago and that
life itself started on our world about
three billion orbits ago when did life
start on your world and let me say it's
a nice hat and then he or she would say
oh it's my helmet it's my space helmet
because your atmosphere is just it's no
good for me and so on I would be I'd
want to know where they came from I'd
want to know why they wanted what were
they doing asking me what I was doing
it'd be great to know though we're not
alone that'd be a heck of a thing it
would change the world
you